un pronunciamiento de la máxima figura
del tribunal supremo de Kenia que
pretende poner fin a días de tensión
política
En consecuencia declaramos válida la
elección de William bruto como
presidente electo de conformidad con el
artículo 143 de la Constitución
el fallo el tribunal confirma la
victoria del ex vicepresidente y ahora
presidente William bruto en las urnas el
pasado 9 de agosto jornada electoral
empañada por un manto de dudas por
posible fraude electoral el rostro más
visible Héroes cuestionamientos Ray
laudinga líder opositor y segundo en
votación se ha presentado cinco veces a
la presidencia del país africano y en
varias oportunidades ha alegado fraude
electoral como en 2017 cuando la
comisión electoral confirmó que hubo un
intento de hackeo al sistema de conteo
esta vez odínga afirma que un equipo de
trabajo de William bruto habría
pirateado el sistema electoral para
cambiar visualización de los resultados
lo que llevó a odinga a presentar la
demanda de la que hoy se conoce el fallo
su ahogado respeta la decisión del
tribunal pero la califica como sesgada
el líder opositor aseguró que acoge la
decisión judicial
si los tribunales deciden lo contrario
básicamente respetaremos la decisión de
los tribunales
Mientras que el electo presidente hizo
un llamado a la unidad de todos los
sectores políticos
por lo tanto extiendo una mano de
hermandad a todos mis competidores y a
sus partidarios no somos enemigos somos
kenianos unámonos para hacer una nación
en la que todos estemos orgullosos de
llamar hogar
Kenia es considerado como el país más
estable de la región y como un Aliado de
occidente en conflictos vecinos como el
de somalia pero actualmente la nación
enfrenta a una enorme deuda y un
encarecimiento de alimentos y
combustible esto sumado a la histórica
disputa ét que también es causa de la
rivalidad entre William bruto y rey
laudinga